welcome
my name is jerusalets and i'm a product
manager on gke
with me on the virtual stage joel mayer
chief architect at openx and ivan gusev
principal infrastructure architect at
opennex
in the next 25 minutes we will show you
how openx looks at performance and cost
how to become a hero metering and
understanding your utilization on gke
how to optimize for what you need and
then
what does it mean in practice so let's
get started
when we talk about cost to performance
optimization on gke
we mentioned the two dimensions for a
reason
while the ultimate amount of your spend
on the infrastructure
depends on the provisioned resources it
is important to understand
your application how it operates and
what you expect from the service it
represents
so is your application stateless or
stateful
is it serving or data processing how
long does it take to start from
deployment to active
and how much time does it need to drain
so a second factor expected slo
of service you are providing
what is the latency of the service that
you expect
can you afford longer startup time
if this means lower cost do you need to
provision for high availability
how does it impact the choice of machine
types and the level of overprovisioning
so how do you do this in practice
let's hear the life story from joel and
evan from openx
thanks jersey so these numbers represent
openx in a nutshell
prior to our migration we were 100
billion requests per day
running 15 million lines of code
deployed on 15 000 servers
around the globe in five different
regions
now openex is an ad exchange and so
those billions of ad requests are coming
from a multitude of clients
with an sla of between 150 to 400
milliseconds depending on the client
and we call this set of services that
handle those requests the delivery
system
and that comprises about half of our
infrastructure cost
so as you can see from the load balancer
stats on the screen we have both a daily
pattern
with peaks and troughs and then a weekly
pattern as well with lower traffic on
weekends and then higher during the week
prior to migration we had a pretty
traditional deployment strategy
services were packaged as rpms and they
were deployed via salt stack on physical
hardware
but we felt that being on prem was
limiting our efficiency
so when we moved to the cloud our goal
was to modernize for the purposes of
gaining efficiency
scalability and consistency and we felt
that kubernetes was the right answer for
that
but we also knew we didn't want to be
running kubernetes ourselves
so when we evaluated the different
offerings from the competitors it seemed
like gke was probably about two years
ahead of everybody else both in terms of
features
and stability
now early on yvonne had looked at the
cpu utilization of all of our services
both at peak and on average to get a
sense of how much compute we'd actually
need in the cloud
and what he found was pretty interesting
so the x-axis here
is peak utilization and the y-axis is
average utilization
now in an on-prem environment your
server count's fixed so unless your
service is running at full tilt all day
long
off-peak is basically wasted compute and
with our diurnal traffic pattern and our
weekend
patterns we had a lot of ways to compute
the graph also illustrated for us that
we could save significantly and compute
cost
if we could buy only what we needed
throughout the day and could share
hardware with auxiliary services
now keep in mind that's this is only one
dimension
of cpu utilization uh we're not looking
at memory or io
those aren't captured either and that's
why some of the numbers may look a
little sad
so the services circled there those are
the delivery system
and we knew that these were the
candidates for gke and that
moving to gke would enable us to scale
compute based on our traffic patterns
and needs
and also to gain efficiency by optimal
packing of the services
on hardware let's take a a brief look at
some of the before and after so on-prem
services were rarely restarted you would
deploy and you would start and it would
run unless there was a problem
also they didn't grow and shrink in
number whereas in the cloud
the pods were very dynamic uh spinning
up spinning down
and also the cluster size was dynamic
growing or shrinking
so we're going from a very static
environment to a very dynamic
environment and that's what we wanted
but it also introduced some challenges
for us
a few other differences worth noting
on-prem hardware is dedicated to a
service
and as a result that service was tuned
for maximum utilization
of that server whereas in the cloud
you're optimizing your pod for the
resources that you've allocated to it
and then you're optimizing your cluster
for overall utilization
so uh what that means practically
speaking is we weren't just migrating
from one containerized environment to
another
we're moving from a very server based
model to a completely
unoptimized container model and that
added a lot of complexity
but what it did mean is that we could go
from using
the fewest service servers possible at
peak to a world where we could provision
only what we needed at any given time
and that was our definition of victory
so we had an idea of what was
technically possible in kubernetes
but we still needed to translate that
into a cost model and to accomplish that
yvonne did some pretty extensive
modeling there are a couple dimensions
to that
first he modeled the type of compute
that we would use
would we be using on demand or could we
benefit from a commitment and use
committed use
or most cost effectively could we use
preemptable nodes
second he translated compute to hosted
services in some cases
rather than running react kv on pvms we
decided
let's take advantage of bigtable let's
take advantage of lb
of load balancing and finally he
adjusted the amount based on our actual
utilization
so that model gave us a good idea of
what we could get to
actually getting to that target
efficiency is the journey that we'd like
to share with you
before we go on the journey of auto
scaling let's recap
what we're dealing with in kubernetes
there are two layers of obstruction
the workout layer where your deploy your
parts and the cluster layer
where you deal with nodes google
kubernetes engine
provides automation at both of these
layers so that
your service works optimally all the
time
the horizontal pod autoscaler or hpa
is adding and removing parts of the same
time
based on the utilization metrics which
can be
cpu utilization or custom metrics like
requests per second or
number of tasks in a pops up queue this
solves for the cases where more requests
call for more machines which would be
likely the case of your serving
front-end
application back-end or pool of
processing workers
but what if the amount of memory or cpu
is not appropriate for your process or
your system cannot scale by adding more
machines easily
take a database or file system as an
example
this is where vertical port autoscaler
comes to rescue it is monitoring the
resource utilization
and allows for adjusting the pod
requests to either
improve performance or reduce unused
resources
similarly on the infrastructure layer
cluster autoscaler automatically adds
and removes nodes in the cluster
this operation happens in response to
pending pod requests
by the scheduler and cpu utilization
of the node node auto-provisioning
decides on the type of node pools on
your behalf
automatically this way cluster
autoscaler
can always keep the most optimal meaning
cheapest configuration of your cluster
so in summary gke is offering
four dimensions of auto scaling to help
you optimize
cost and performance of your workloads
so how did openx use them to optimize
for cost
thank you jersey glad to be here
horizontal pod auto scalers allow each
deployment
to scale independently while maintaining
each
pod workload at nearly constant rate
this significantly reduces the number of
performance scenarios that need to be
tested and
optimized for we found that for most
workloads
cpu utilization targets work
best as changes in code often change
execution
efficiency and would need to be
constantly adjusted if a custom metric
is used as a global company we also
observed
regional differences in the code
execution path
this can significantly complicate
application rating for
particular workload volumes
metrics are still useful if your
workload is not cpu bound
but rather io or network bound
remember kubernetes does not give you
explicit choice over pod deletion
process
when deployment is scaled down
kubernetes observes
but disruption budget while randomly
selecting
a plot to scale down this creates the
this creates imbalance in utilization of
nodes
cluster of the scalar normally takes
care of underutilized nodes
if you need an additional control you
can use the scheduler
an open source project helping to
balance resource
utilization of nodes
when a cluster has one or more pods
pending the cluster autoscaler kicks in
and determines what node pools can
and should increase in size to
accommodate these workloads
to choose the best option it considers
fitness
of each node configuration to
accommodate
pending pods in other words how well
particular node size will match pods
that need to be scheduled
it also takes into account an estimated
cost of cluster size increase
and will attempt to increase multiple
node pools
sequentially should some kind of
fold or stock out event be detected
and open x we started with very
prescriptive model
when we defined exactly what node pool
will host each
workload however that often meant that
there is only one application
per node one application pod per node
when we allowed the cluster autoscaler
to choose the best node pool dynamically
we found that
provisioned virtual machines match our
workloads
much more closely which
uses less memory and less cpu
we waste less gk author
also offers fast scale down cluster of
the scalar profile
which removes underutilized nodes much
more rapidly
thus lowering the cost of your cluster
faster joe back to you
thanks yvonne so yvonne just described
the benefits
of the horizontal pod auto scaler and
the cluster auto scaling
once we had implemented both of those
our compute usage began to follow our
traffic patterns
both the diurnal daily pattern and the
weekly pattern which you can see on the
slide there
that's the beauty of auto scaling when
it's enabled at the application layer
and at the hardware layer it translates
into cost efficiency
let's take a brief side journey to talk
about measurement so optimization
without measurement is
nearly impossible you need to you need
visibility into your starting point and
where your resources are being consumed
so you need the ability to measure
improvement
you want to understand your pod
utilization how are they performing
you want to understand your node
utilization how many are being used and
to what extent
you also need to understand your overall
cost because at the end of the day
that's what matters
so really you'd love to measure
everything and we used a combination of
different tools to accomplish that
first we used prometheus and grafana
to measure service metrics and
application metrics all our services
were instrumented
and kubernetes offers those metrics out
of the box as well
then we also used bigquery to track the
cost metrics that gcp makes available
and there's an entire separate talk on
that topic which we encourage you to
check out
and then finally we use the gke metering
dashboard to see which services we're
consuming the most resources and cost
when it comes to optimization your
destination is the model you've created
and measurement is your gps it tells you
how far you've come and also how far
you've got to go
let's talk about some of the next stops
on our optimization journey
sure with hpa and cluster autoscaling
configured we
next looked at pod optimization
for the average case pod tuning is a
matter of making sure you
understand ratio of ram and cpu needed
for the application
to operate at certain throughput then
you just set
requests and limits accordingly in some
cases you may also need to tune
underlying technology like jvm if
needed if your pod isn't utilizing the
requested resources
you can reduce the request which will
release the capacity
back to the cluster if your pod
consistently
over utilizing the requests requested
resources then
you may need to increase requests in
order to improve
service continuity have you seen out of
memory killer in action
gke provides vertical pod auto scaler
that
watches your quad resource utilization
and
recommends odd sizes it is
an automated way of process that we use
that open x
vertical portal of scaling does three
things
it watches the resource usage by the
selected bots
after it collects enough data it
provides recommendations to
what should be the actual resource that
should be specified in the bot spec and
then
if enabled it applies the recommendation
to selected bots
you can apply the recommendations
yourself similarly to what openx did
with their workloads
you can also enable automatic actuation
of your bots
according to the recommendations this
can happen in two ways
at both creation time or continuously
the vpa recommendations that jersey just
described are incredibly useful
and another gke feature that enabled us
to optimize performance
was cpu manager which yvonne is going to
tell us a little bit more about
sure just like the noisy neighbor effect
on virtual machines
a similar effect exists for pods
sometimes that's by design to achieve
overall higher
virtual machine utilization however
openx runs a large number of
applications
written in erlang and airline virtual
machine has its own scheduler threads
which work most efficiently if they run
on the same cpu core
all the time and aren't swapped out or
competing for
cpu with other applications
for scenarios like this kubernetes has a
feature called
cpu manager it provides additional
guarantees of
cpu allocation on top of what kubernetes
resource requests
are already doing while resource
requests
are only used by kubernetes scheduler to
make
informed decisions on where to schedule
pods
the cpu manager enforces cpu allocation
to the pod
continuously prohibiting all other parts
from stepping into
cpu-managed spot territory and
minimizing the number of
contact switches the flip side of cpu
manager is that
pod cannot exceed their requests
and efficiently sandboxed in terms of
cpu capacity
for our airline systems that's exactly
what we wanted
so with auto scaling enabled and our
pods tuned we still needed to tackle
another area of optimization
how do we make the most use of a cluster
that has diverse set of services running
in it
so in a nutshell how do we optimally bin
pack there are two parts to that
challenge
one how do we size our pods so they're
more easily accessible
and then two how do we size our nodes so
that they can accommodate the right
number of pods
we have some control over both
dimensions so we needed to find a sweet
spot
kubernetes scheduler takes several pods
properties into consideration to make
decision on what node plot gets
scheduled
two primary capacity related fields are
resource requests for cpu and memory
kubernetes scheduler does not scale
cluster
up or down but rather works with
available nodes
aiming to fit as many pods as possible
into provisioned capacity and when this
is not possible
and pods are pending cluster autoscaler
provisions
more nodes here's an example of cpu and
memory constraint modes
on the left graph you can see that even
though
only 78 of cpu capacity is
allocated no pods larger than four cpus
can be scheduled
similarly on high cpu node scheduler
node scheduler cannot add any new
parts because the single pod has already
allocated pretty much all memory
capacity
so we ended up with cpu resource
utilization of
just 28 percent
how can this impact inefficiency can
can it be improved you can make all pods
equal size and make sure that each node
can fit
exactly and pods this is not
always ideal as workload capacity
requirements
and ability to scale vertically differ a
lot
at open x we use 2 to the power of n
rule
we standardize spot sizes on 1 2 4
and 16 cores this also
matches gce standard vm sizes and
allows us to move between different vm
sizes without a need to optimize quad
sizes again
while doing so make sure that you
account for space reserved by kubernetes
for demon sets and kernel also don't
forget to pay attention to your
site car and init containers as their
resource requests
might be affecting scheduling decisions
generally speaking you will get best
results of bin packing
when pod requests are small fractions of
cpus
while nodes are relatively large
yet if you're using preemptable virtual
machines
you have to watch for losing large
number of pods
in case of preemption
measuring bin packing efficiency is
quite simple
as you need to aggregate all workload
resource requests
and divide it by total capacity
it can be tracked as a cluster-wide
metric or
notable specific ratio we observed that
auto-scaled clusters with
no pod size optimizations we usually get
around 75 percent of
cpu reserved while clusters with
improved mean pack and efficiency reach
all the way to 95
similar optimizations can be done for
memory dimension
however memory generally requires
significant headroom and usage is
less predictable compared to cpu cores
our memory
reservations are currently measured at
around 50 percent
optimization of bin packing is more than
in more than one dimension is totally
possible
but depending on your workload profile
it may end up
exponentially harder to implement with
every new
dimension that you add we decided to
leave this exercise for the future
joel so early on
when we were doing our cloud cost
modeling yvonne picked out services that
could take advantage of preemptable
virtual machines
and for the delivery stack we assumed
that roughly 70
of our compute could be preemptable now
when we first tested we were discouraged
because it was hard to get the pvm
capacity we needed
but after discussing with the gce team
they encouraged us to try a smaller
sized pvm node
after making that change we were much
more successful in finding the pvm
capacity
and we've even exceeded our initial
target pvm utilization
but it is another factor to consider in
bin packing
so the gke cluster auto scaler allows us
to tap into different pvm pools by
attempting to scale up different node
pools sequentially
that could be node pools of different vm
sizes or using different
compute families
so while we've presented our journey as
a nice linear progression
the reality was a bit more winding with
some back and forth between the
different optimization techniques
that being said the six approaches we've
discussed are all worth looking into
first configure and tune your horizontal
pod auto scalers
to enable the cluster auto scaler three
right size your pod request and or
use the vertical pod auto scaler number
four
use the cpu manager for the applications
that need that level of guarantee
number five optimize your bin packing
and then number six
find the right machine type for your
workload so
thanks to the work that avon and the
team have done we're now able to run our
gke clusters on a very small set of node
pools that scale based on price and
availability
and thanks to the optimized pods the
hpas the right choices and machine sizes
we've improved efficiency by over 45
percent
one of the things that was invaluable to
the success of this project was the
ability to meet with
and ask questions of the different uh
teams whose technology we're using
whether that was jersey and the gke auto
scalers team
the cpu manager team the gce team or
any one of the other teams that we met
with
we're really impressed by their
willingness to uh to work with us and
help us use their technology
we also took advantage of the gcp pso
team to help us in various parts of the
migration
and found their help to be very valuable
as well thank you particularly to will
bebe
so jersey thanks for allowing us to
share some of our story here with you
and uh to the audience good luck with
your own optimization efforts
jersey back to you thank you joel and
yvonne for
sharing your experience with us for
those of you
willing to get on a journey of
optimizing cost of performance on gke
we just published two solution guides
that will get you an advice on
best practices of running cost effective
kubernetes applications
and how to use node auto provisioning
to optimize your resources these guides
are a collective summary of experiences
of openx and many other companies
who shared their stories with us we will
keep updating it
as we add more functionality to google
kubernetes engine
you should also take a look at related
breakout sessions
airing this week on behalf of google
cloud team
i want to thank you for watching